welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books this episode is for
those who are strong with the force and
have managed to complete Star Wars Jedi
fallen order and have questions about
the game and it's ending throughout this
video I'm going to be discussing the
full storyline of the New Jedi epic and
giving my thoughts on the game as we go
through it there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't played through
all the fallen order yet and don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you submit to the dark side and
leave this video without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Star Wars Jedi fallen order
okay so the game picks up five years
after order 66 was carried out by Darth
Sidious without so much as a McConkey in
sight those who survived the purge have
scattered themselves throughout the
galaxy hiding from the long arm of the
Empire obi-wan fled to Tatooine Yoda
today Gabbar and our game's protagonist
Kyle castus found a home on the planet
Bracker as a junkyard scrapper Cal
pretty much keeps himself to himself
hiding his powers from everyone and
because of this the ex padawan has
evaded the Empire's gaze however one day
he is forced to use his powers to save
his friend profe who almost falls to his
death
Cal is desperate to maintain a low
profile but he quickly finds himself a
target and the Empire dispatches two
inquisitors to find the Jedi and kill
him it's an awesome introduction and a
beautiful Erie captures the feeling of
classic Star Wars films in a brilliant
way this opening level is like a blast
from the past and fleeing from the
Empire on a ridiculously fast train got
my blood pumping
early on in these sections the opening
really makes you relate to Cal and see
that he's just a guy trying to do the
right thing
he's reluctantly shoved back into the
spotlight and watching second sister
kill prowl for really struck a chord
with me even though it was a character
that I'd only known for about half an
hour when all hope looks lost Cal is
rescued by an ex Jedi named SIA and her
pilot friend Gries who both operate a
ship known as the man
dis CA has closed herself off from the
force so she needs Cal for the journey
ahead and there are also love elements
that come up from her past that play
massively into the story as it goes on
aboard the Mantis they travel to pagano
where an ancient Jedi vault is located
which is where Cal comes across a droid
named BD 1 BD 1 would be the cutest
thing in Star Wars right now but
unfortunately for it it got beat last
minute by baby Yoda we stand for baby
Yoda inside the vault Cal discovers a
message from Sears Master cut over that
says that he has a list of for sensitive
children hidden somewhere and that this
group could one day topple the Empire
before he can access it though Cal needs
to pass some tests to prove that he is
worthy and whilst it's very video game
II actually love traveling planet to
planet leveling up and fighting all
manner of men and monsters and women too
don't forget you hit some women in this
as well no I didn't say that I loved it
but if I never had to go back to
Dathomir again I'd be happy but on the
whole it's a really engaging game that
feels like it's constantly dangling a
carrot in front of you to keep you
pushing forward I have a couple of
friends who also bought the game that
said they found this constant tracking
boring but personally I loved unlocking
shortcuts traversing new routes that
allowed me to explore it before then
diving further into the area just to see
how grand that it really was add to this
the combat system of fallen order and
you have a match made in heaven now you
aren't exactly Yoda or even baby Yoda
for that matter we stand for you and
taking on things without planning is
gonna get you killed pretty quickly it's
very embarrassing being murdered by a
little creature that's only half your
height but it shows just how much you
have to be careful when taking all those
on just because you have a lightsaber
doesn't mean that you have it easy and
running into groups without choosing
your first target carefully you can lead
to you being killed in a moment's notice
there's a steep learning curve to it and
Dathomir Oda thermia how you kick the
crap out of me when I thought I was just
gonna be going for a trot through the
fields however once you get the hang of
everything it becomes brilliant each
battle feels and throwing and energetic
with you constantly having to cautiously
block and then let go of the
at the opportune moment in order to
strike blocking at the right moment also
allows you to parry and can send blaster
bolts back at their attacker however you
have to wait until the last second to do
this so it's a gamble that sometimes
doesn't pay off over although it makes
you really practice with the game and
just as Cal grows throughout the story
remastering his powers the player does
to Cal and the group travel took
Kashyyyk encountering saw herrera from
rogue one before going to zephyr where
he comes face to face with second sister
once more here we get one of the first
big twists with it being revealed that
the sister is sears padawan named Trillo
who is a student of Darth Vader now
under torture see revealed trellis
location and this has led her down a
dark path it's a nice humanizing moment
for the villain and adds a lot of weight
to her choices many people in a similar
position would probably turn to the dark
side instead of facing death and she's a
memorable foe for the game
truely informs Cal at SIA has been in
touch with the dark side and she says
that she will betray Cal just as she
betrayed her we later learn that this is
why SIA cut herself off from the force
as she didn't want to go down a dog path
no matter how much easier life would be
for her it's a great back-and-forth that
makes you question whether SIA wants the
list for the right reasons or if this is
all a big play for her Cal is captured
by a bounty hunter and forced to fight
in an arena for the entertainment of a
crime lord but once more he's rescued by
grease and SIA they returned to cash
chic to speak to traful who instructs
Cal to travel to the origin tree now was
it just me or did bits of this remind
people of neverending story anyway look
there he gets a message from Kotova
telling him to go to Dathomir no thanks
end the game sell it on eBay and yeah
that's that's the game over no we're not
we're not oh we're gonna have to go
aren't we
anyway he's attacked by nine sister who
Cal manages to defeat and he returns to
Dathomir when he arrives there he's
confronted by night sister Marin who
hates the Jedi for killing her people
during the Clone Wars and she pretty
much puts a roadblock after roadblock in
his way and yeah you're best off just
going through most of this without
resting because it's not nice having the
enemies respawn especially on the
hardest difficulty
I love you Marin eventually but um yeah
this was not fun
Cal comes face to face with another Jedi
named Taryn who says he can help Cal
harness the dark power of Dathomir and
we get an awesome flashback of order 66
in which Kyle remembers his time when
the clone troopers turned bad
we were ruined for you clone II we were
all room for you Gero protected Kyle
from the attack and this is how he was
able to escape
Gero spirits seemingly returns and he
fights with Cal which ends up destroying
the protagonists lightsaber Taryn wants
to tempt Cal with the darkness but he
refuses and please
traveling to illumine to get a Kyber
crystal to rebuild his blade Cal wants
more fights Jaros spirit but this time
he conquers the doubt guilt and fear he
faced in his death and therefore he
bests the dark feelings within him
Terran can't take the hint and tries to
tempt Cal again who refuses and this
sends Taryn into a rage he even gets
double lightsabers out which year oh I
did not enjoy that fight Marin joins the
battle and sides with Cal after a
heart-to-heart and Taryn is finally
vanquished and Marin and subduing the
crew of the Mantis the group returned to
began oh and Cal finally unlocks the
vault and gets the holocron with the
names on it
trailer pops up and steals this though
and escapes SIA wants more resumes her
position as a Jedi Master and officially
makes Cal a Jedi Knight and the group
then attacked the Inquisitor
headquarters Cal takes on trilha in
order to get the holocron back and he
manages to defeat her in what is an
awesome boss pal also is it me or did
anyone else get kylo Ren vibes from
trailer yeah just just something I
picked up
anyway Cal was going to strike her down
but sear intervenes and tries to turn
her back to the light SIA admits that
she failed trailer and that all her
choices pushed her into darkness and
just as you think the two are finally
going to be friends once more we hear
the unforgettable breathing noise of
Darth Vader Vader kills trailer and
pretty much redecorate the room pilling
floor panels ceilings and Cal about the
place running from star wars most famous
bad guy really gets your heart racing
and it's an awesome way to ramp up the
game for its final chapter
Vader makes Cal stab himself and SIA
battles the Sith Lord embracing the dark
side of her personality in order to hold
him back
pair managed to get away and they make
it back to the Mantis with the holocron
seer releases Greece hours contract but
he says he wants to stick around and the
crew decide what to do next with the
holocron it boils down to do things
where they can either gather the
children rebuilding the Jedi Knights and
using them to fight the Empire or they
don't and they let the children live our
lives where they aren't living in
constant fear of the Empire hunting them
down both have their pros and cons and
are pretty tough decisions but Cowell
realizes that the destinies of others
should not be in the hands of the group
this kind of mirrors seers choices
eventually leading to the downfall of
trilha and kal decides that their
destiny should be decided by the force
he destroys the holocron so the Empire
can't have it either and this kind of
ties in with the vision that kal had
earlier in the game in which he
witnessed the Jedi being slaughtered and
he knew that this prophecy had a high
chance of coming true and thus decided
that the best course of action to take
was to keep the Jedi separate its moves
like this that allowed Luke to rise up
and take the Empire out and it's quite a
smart storytelling motif that feels like
what a true Jedi would actually do these
are protectors of the peace through and
through and kal would rather not
sacrifice lives if it's unnecessary it's
quite a mature ending and there's
actually a lot of comic books and
additional Star Wars material that have
dealt with a similar aesthetic in those
the Jedi that rose up will quickly stamp
down due to their lack of practice and
knowledge of the force and there are a
lot of instances where Padawan were
killed early on by the forces of the
Empire in order to stop them from
becoming threats kal realized that if
they were to round up this list it would
give the Emperor and Vader easy access
to them and this would wipe out all hope
in the galaxy leaving Cal and Coe in a
far worse position SIA and Cal are
haunted by their past so much due to the
trauma that comes from it and this
ending is really just about moving on
the entire game is about trying to
return things to how they were but in
the end they realize that they have to
go beyond this in order to progress as
Marin said all that awaited those
children was war and death or being
turned into inquisitors so Cal made the
right decision what this also does is
leave everything open for a sequel which
I really hope we get but what did I
think of the game
well as I'm sure you can guess I
absolutely loved it
I've craved a single-player Star Wars
game for so long now and after the
cancellation of 1313 and place of
battlefront I thought we wouldn't get
one for a while I was desperate for this
to be good and I'm glad to say that it
didn't disappoint it's got everything in
it that helpful from a Star Wars game
including incredible Easter eggs the
balance of comedy drama and cuteness and
overall it knocked it out of the park in
my opinion though it takes a while
getting used to once you're on board
with this it's a brilliant game and I
can't really recommend it high enough
fall in order is an amazing rise of the
Star Wars game and that's why it gets a
9 out of 10 now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on fall in order so
make sure you leave your review in the
comment section below if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up make sure you check out our full
breakdown on baby Yoda which should be
linked at the end we go over the best
theories for the character and discuss
where the Mandalorian could be going so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
that early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so I hope they
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and fall in order in the
comments section below
when it's gonna be chosen on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped up
from then trooper gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part
this is a channel for the hardcore
players so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks for taking
the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you